hello everyone my name is Jonathan dweck
and I'm an operations engineer here at
SpaceX
I'll be your host for today's starlink
Mission which marks spacex's 18th launch
of the year and 217th overall mission to
date
and today we're sending another 52
Starling satellites to orbit
currently weather and range are both
looking good and we're proceeding with a
t-0 time of 12 26 PM Pacific time from
Vandenberg space Force Base at pad 4
East
the teams are currently tracking no
issues with the vehicle or spacecraft
we should start to see the clamp arms
start to open up around the payload
fairing just at the top of your screen
there
and there you have it those clamp arms
have started to open in preparation for
launch
now those clamp arms are connected to
our transporter erector also known as
the te and this is that large truss
structure next to the rocket that's used
for rollout and to route propellants and
electrical power to the vehicle in
preparation for launch
foreign
has also started to retract away from
the vehicle as we gear up for launch
here
it's a gorgeous day up in Vandenberg you
see the Pacific Ocean just behind the
falcon 9. next Milestone that we're
tracking is stage one locks load
complete we expect that to occur in
around 15 seconds from now
stage one lock float complete
and there you heard that call out
T minus three minutes the Falcon 9 first
stage has completed its locked loading
next we're waiting the completion of
locks load on our second stage in around
45 seconds from now
and once that's complete this will
conclude propellant loading on the
entire vehicle
those white clouds that you're seeing
around Falcon 9 are completely normal
during propellant loading we vent cold
gas that forms above the Lox tank
surface and what you're seeing is the
result of that cold gas coming in
contact with the warmer California air
and condensing
again if you're in the Vandenberg area
should be some beautiful views today
just expecting to hear that call out
first second stage locks the complete
any moment now
stage two locks load complete
and there you heard it as well Falcon 9
is now fully loaded with one million
pounds of fuel and liquid oxygen
and we're getting some venting there
from our transporter erector as we just
prepare for launch
booster that you see on your screen is
flying for its eighth time today having
previously supported sorrow one SWAT NRL
85 and 87 and three starlink missions
coming up next Falcon 9 will enter its
startup phase
Falcon 9 is in startup
you heard that call it as well Falcon 9
is now on internal power now we're just
waiting to hear from the launch director
with our final go no go for launch today
LDS go for lunch the launch director has
given the final one to proceed for
launch now let's sit back and watch as
the Falcon 9 takes our 52 Starling
satellites into space
T-minus 30 seconds
15 seconds
2 minus ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one engine Soul Tower
hamlets off darling 2-8 go falcon go
starling
vehicles
t plus 30 seconds Falcon 9 has
successfully lifted off from
vandenberg's space launch complex four
East at 12 26 PM Pacific time this is
our fifth launch from Vandenberg just
this year
power and Telemetry nominal
Pelican 9 is supersonic
with that call out Falcon 9 is now
traveling faster than the speed of sound
Q
and there you heard that call out for
Max Q this means that the vehicle is
currently experiencing the greatest
amount of external stresses as it
ascends through Earth's atmosphere on
its way to space
foreign
we're just about one minute away from a
series of events Mikko stageep ses1 and
fairing separation
Mikko or main engine cutoff is where all
nine of the Merlin 1D engines on the
first stage shut down
stage separation is when the first and
second stages separate
ses1 or second engine start one is where
we light the single Merlin vacuum engine
on the second stage
and fairing separation is when those two
fairing halves separate and fall away
from the second stage keep an eye out
for those events
going to be happening in rather quick
succession
Mikko stage separation confirmed
[Applause]
and back ignition
bearing separation confirmed
and there you have those vents again
that was Mikko stage step ses1 and as
you saw fairing separation
we'll be attempting to recover both
fairing halves using our recovery vessel
NRC quests
both of the fairing halves flying on
today's missions are flight proven and
are flying for the fifth time
and just a reminder on the left hand
side of your screen is the Falcon 9
first stage making its way back down to
earth on the right is the second stage
carrying our Starling satellites into
orbit
currently the first stage is on its way
back to Earth towards our drone ship of
course I still love you which is
positioned in the Pacific Ocean
and a reminder our first stage is on the
left hand side of your screen
if successful was today's Landing
attempt this will Mark our 179th overall
Landing of an orbital class rocket
and the mvac engine on the right hand
side of your screen attached to our
second stage is continuing its burn this
should last for another several minutes
here
as I mentioned earlier today's Starling
Mission Mark spacex's 217th Mission
overall an 18th Mission just this year
both vehicles continue to follow nominal
trajectories
and there you heard that stage one and
stage two are both following nominal
trajectories
as a reminder starlink is a satellite
internet constellation designed and
manufactured by SpaceX to provide
high-speed low latency internet to
people living in remote and Rural
locations around the globe
coming up in about a minute or so we
expect stage one entry burn
this is the point at which the first
stage will re-light three of its Merlin
1D engines in preparation for landing
and we expect that entry burn to begin
in just around 40 seconds from now
getting some really spectacular views of
the earth behind both our mvac on the
right hand side of your screen and
through those two grid friends on our
first stage on the left hand side
stage one entry burn startup
there's that call out for stage one
entry burn stage one which we also refer
to as the booster has ignited engines
one five and nine just load down for
atmospheric re-entry
the first stage used to launch our 52
Starling satellites into space today is
flying for its eighth time stage one
entry burn shutdown having previously
supported sorrow one SWAT
nrol85 and 87 and three previous
starlink missions
and as you saw we had stage one entry
burn shutdown
stage one FTS has saved
coming up next will be our stage one
Landing burn this will be the final burn
on our first stage and this is H2 FTS
has saved
the point this would be in preparation
for landing on our drone ship
stage one transonic
and there's that call out that our first
stage is transonic which means it's
traveling near the speed of sound
terminal guidance
stage one Landing burn
and there's that confirmation that the
stage one Landing run has begun in
preparation for touchdown on our drone
ship of course I still love you just
coming into frame now on the left-hand
side of your screen
Stage One Lending leg deploy
stage one Landing confirmed
Falcon 9 has successfully landed on our
drone ship of course I still love you in
the Pacific Ocean this marks our 179th
overall Landing of an orbital class
rocket including F9 and Falcon heavy
missions
nominal orbit insertion
and we just heard that call it as well
for nominal orbital insertion of our
second stage and our Starling satellites
and with confirmation of successful
first stage Landing in good orbit from
our second stage that wraps up our
coverage for now